je laime un peu
beaucoup
passionnément
à la folie
il est où l'avion je laime un peu
beaucoup
mais mes françois qu'est ce qui te prend
on est en hiver la mena de la nature
d'or et toitures ou cool comme une
palombe sous ecstasy
enfin françois toi président en moi
désolé faut agir moi je commence à mieux
comprendre pourquoi tu étais tellement
inquiet pour ta prostate parce que
quand on a besoin en ce moment
[Applaudissements]
non mais je sais mais c'est quand même
passionnant si ce qui se passe bien on
est verni la chance d'avoir dans la tête
depuis une semaine cette image de
hollande en train de culbuter une meuf
c'est
moi c'est énorme et c'est simple mois
depuis les vidéos pornos sur le thème
des femmes enceintes j'ai jamais été
autant excité
alors parce qu'il faut pas se mentir on
a tous envie d'imaginer hollande en
levrette c'est ben oui mais bien sûr
mais s'il vous plaît soyez sérieux quoi
comment il s'y prend comment ils bougent
tu te raconte les sionnel tu imagines
arrivé tout fringant tu vois sur le
scooter persona gauche pour sandra de
bam la pompadour le truc
alors on dit que c'est une affaire
privée c'est pas vrai pendant que
hollande cavale comme un ado qui fait
l'amour à la france
mais
maintenant tout s'explique c'est là son
envie du mariage pour tous c'est normal
moi ya de concurrence plus ya de choix
c'est comme ça non mais le mec qui gère
sa double vie comme un héros du miel et
les abeilles je veux dire quoi quand tu
penses que mitterrand a réussi à cacher
sa fille pendant 20 ans
non parce que lui en termes de
camouflage il n'est pas prêt pour
rejoindre la légion étrangère
total à la ilaha
[Applaudissements]
illa arrive à se faire gauler dans le
quartier le plus surveillé de paris par
un paparazzi de closer doit sa maîtresse
et l'habitat 150 mètres de l'elysée sur
ses 150 mètres tu passes devant le
ministère de l'intérieur les rg
l'ambassade américaine l'ambassade
israélienne et lui se fait gauler comme
un lapin dans les salles en fait j'ai eu
le feu
alors
évidemment comme d'habitude la droite a
réagi avec l'intelligence qui la
caractérise donc par la voix de
christian jacob
non mais jacobs est rien contre lui je
dire si tu le mets dans l'amour est dans
le pré tu tiens l'albert jacquard de la
saison c'est pas
à l'assemblée nationale c'est plus tendu
pas toute cette affaire il dit harvey
toute cette affaire ça monte qu'à une
faille dans la sécurité du président
au lieu d'en profiter
petit matin mme morano déguisé en
bouchehr lefebvre guéant en embuscade
dans une vieille r5 c'est la fine équipe
du 92 bam dans la fourgonnette
parachutage du colis dans une zone
tribale au sahel françois il est ou au
lent
mais bon il est chamboulée il est
chamboulée c'est normal il est en train
de découvrir le sexe
[Applaudissements]
au début c'est perturbant mais il arrive
à le cacher comme il peut alors certains
tombent dans le panneau et tout le monde
est tombé dans le panneau ici oui mais à
la conférence de presse il
impressionnait il a dit oui je suis
social démocrate mais non il est pas
social démocrate il est amoureux
parce qu'en ce moment c'est un ado il
raconte n'importe quoi je veux dire pas
tu connais les ados moi j'en ai une part
on vient de se séparer parce qu'elle
trouve un peu immature
une ado c'est quoi tu vois cette semaine
il est social démocrate la semaine
prochaine il est gothique puis dans un
mois il va porter un t-shirt les jeunes
avec giscard
[Applaudissements]
là
la cri cri d'amour il faut laisser
galoper au lieu de le contredire faut
laisser couler et oued du donne de
l'argent poche pour son flipper et je
lui achète une boîte de capotes un des
os une bouteille d'eau précieuse l'asie
alors forcément à un moment ils devaient
quand même parler de son histoire de
fesses moi je m'attendais à un truc
pittoresque un truc comme sarko tu
aurais carla c'est du sérieux lui joue
je le voyais dire avec valérie c'est du
sursis
alors on lui demande mais comment va la
première dame et lui qui répond elle se
repose tête a l'impression qu'ils
partent sa grand-mère oublié dans un
hospice sur la côte d'azur
quand il a dit ça j'imagine déjà
valoches en train de nourrir des signes
en blouse blanche mais heureuse j'ai
même qui vas tu vois
il paraît qu'elle récupère surtout si on
lui a rapporté le elle de cette semaine
et doit être
laissée laissez le tranquille qu'est
vollandes les ce1 il faut qu'ils
s'éclatent
bah ouais tu vois gérons tout le monde
le pouce choisi des sites wall e shop de
simplification alors pour se renseigner
moi j'ai suivi les statuts facebook des
intéressés trierweiler en couple mais
c'est compliqué
gaye est célibataire mais ça se précise
et lui il a marqué c'est compliqué mais
j'ai prévu de créer un observatoire du
sentiment amoureux qui prendra la
décision
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bien sûr il n'est pas seul dans cette
histoire en face il ya une autre dame
qui piaffent est pourquoi l pourquoi
julie gayet alors faut être honnête fin
il s'est pas mis avec elle pour sa
filmographie son
nom c'est c'est pas être méchant que
dire ça je veux dire devant la meuf
révélé en 96 par delphine 1 yvan 0 c'est
le seul film français que la lucidité
d'annoncer le nombre d'entrées dans son
titre
[Applaudissements]
à kennedy a démarré ligne tu les chanter
poupoupidou au congrès alors là on va on
va vers quoi tend à la bellevilloise une
meuf qui va chanter le temps des cerises
pour une galette ou quinoa afin que
d'autres
pas sont des sujets plus sérieux santé
bouteflika hospitalisé au val de grâce
qu'est ce qu'il ya lieu il a fait une
chute de ski à méribel a fait un
bond qui soit venu devant se soigner en
france c'est quand même la veux qu'on a
eu la colonisation un peu mesquine
non mais bon c'est pas de notre faute si
j'avais été un peu moins obnubilés par
leur désir d'indépendance
en plus des routes et des égouts on
aurait pu laisser un système de santé
qui marche
c'est une idée bon bonne nouvelle de la
semaine y en at il une wii a le ballon
d'or a été remis à cristiano ronaldo
certains disent que ribéry ne mérite et
oui mais qui aurait traduit son disco
alors à balayer les corrections de ne
rien rater le 1h10 tube abonnez vous il
mettait un peu de bleu